I'm a lion conservationist sounds cool
doesn't it some people may have no idea
what that means but I'm sure you have
all heard about Cecil the lion heroes
normal on the 2nd of July 2015 his life
was cut short when he was killed by a
trophy hunter they say that you can
become attached to the animals you
studied there was the case for me wizzy
sued a lion having known him and studied
him for 3 years in one gained national
park I was heartbroken at his death but
the good thing to come out of this
tragedy is the attention that the story
brought towards the plight of threatened
wild animals after sis was dead I began
to ask myself these questions what if
the community that lived next to Cecil
the lion was involved in protecting him
what if I had met Cecil when I was 10
years old
instead of 29 could I all my classmates
have changed his fate many people are
working to stop Lions from disappearing
but very few of these people are native
to these countries or from the
communities most affected but the
communities that live with the Lions are
the ones best positioned to help Lions
the most local people should be at the
forefront of the solutions to the
challenges facing their world life
sometimes change can only come when the
people most affected and impacted take
charge local communities play an
important role in fighting poaching and
illegal wildlife trade which are major
traits affecting lions and other
wildlife being a black African woman in
their sciences the people I meet are
always curious to know if I've always
wanted to be a conservationist because
they don't meet a lot of
conservationists who look like me when I
was growing up I didn't even know that
wildlife conservation was a career the
first time that I saw a wild animal in
my home country was when I was 25 years
old even though Lions in African wild
dogs lived just a few miles away from my
home this is quite common in Zimbabwe as
many people are not exposed to our life
even though it's part of our heritage
when I was growing up I didn't even know
that Lions lived in my backyard when I
stepped into sari Valley Conservancy on
a cold winter morning 10 years ago to
study African Wild Dogs
for my master's research project I was
mesmerized by the beauty and the
tranquility that surrounded me I felt
like I had found my passion in my
purpose in life I made a commitment that
day that I was going to dedicate my life
to protecting animals I think of my
childhood school days in Zimbabwe and
the other kids I was in school with
perhaps if we had a chance to interact
with wildlife more of my classmates
would be working alongside me now unless
the local communities want to protect
and coexist with wildlife all
conservation efforts might be in vain
these are the communities that live with
the world animals in the same ecosystem
and bear the cost of doing so if they
don't have a direct connection or
benefit from the animals they have no
reason to want to protect them and if
knuckle communities don't protect their
wildlife no amount of outside
intervention will work so what needs to
be done conservationists must prioritize
environmental education and help expand
the community skills to conserve their
wildlife school children and communities
must be taken to national parks so they
get a chance to connect with the
wildlife at every effort and every level
conservation must include the economies
of the people who share the land with
the wild animals it is also critical
that local conservationist be part of
every conservation effort if you had to
build
trust and really embed conservation into
communities as local conservationist we
face many headers from outright
discrimination to barriers because of
cultural norms but I will not give up my
efforts to bring indigenous communities
to this fight for the survival of our
planet I'm asking you to come and stand
together with me
we must actively dismantle the hedgerows
we have created which are living
indigenous populations out of
conservation efforts I have dedicated my
life to protecting lions and I know my
neighborhood too if only they knew the
animals that lived next door to them
thank you
[Applause]